we should tell you and as we said at the
top this is the only hour on american
television that is not
broadcasting unfiltered propaganda
into the homes of unsuspecting viewers
on the screen you see eight boxes those
are eight different tv channels
taking the nancy pelosi feed
unfiltered
now if at any time in your life you've
ever made fun of totalitarian regimes
that you know
broadcast
lies into the homes of the population
that they can't turn off
take a look at that that's happening
right now
meanwhile gas is over five bucks
inflation is higher than it's been in
the lifetime of most americans violent
crime is making cities impossible to
live in and more than a hundred thousand
americans odd on drugs last year
why isn't there a prime time hearing
about any of that
charlie hurt is the opinion editor of
the washington times he joins us tonight
charlie great to see you i mean
if you take three steps back what we're
really watching is
members of congress talking about
themselves again
yeah absolutely because the alternative
is for them to have to talk about
policies and if they talk about policies
they have to talk about their and it's
not just their failures of you know all
the failures we see right in front of us
you know gas prices crime an open border
fentanyl deaths you can go through
the list is endless and if anybody got
out of washington any of these people
got out of washington and talked to
normal people they would realize that
american people are very very concerned
about a lot of things this is not one of
them but then but then you step back
even farther and you look at the the
just the cavalcade of lies that the
democrat politicians have made in their
promises to get elected over ever since
uh even before joe biden became uh came
to washington whether it's uh solving
health care problems for poor people
ending poverty or uh providing public
education to people they failed on all
of these fronts and the reason and i
call this the the third failed
impeachment trial of donald j trump the
reason they have to talk about this
stuff is because they can't talk about
those other issues they have to distract
everybody from but but then it's even
crazier than that because when you get
to the issue of security and you start
thinking about what people
you know whose businesses were destroyed
in these riots that democrats supported
in the year running up to the election
and you think about the security think
about the parents whose children that
they fear for their children going into
an elementary school today and democrats
control all both chambers of congress
and the white house they have not done a
damn thing to protect children in
schools yeah uh
beyond that the the third branch of
government the judiciary we have supreme
court justices living under the threat
of their family being assassinated and
and that and nancy pelosi will do
nothing about it all she can talk about
is this day a year and a half ago when
she was afraid or they were afraid of
some goofball trespassing
nutty rioters coming through the capitol
i i think that what we're seeing and i
think all this is going to backfire and
i think what we're seeing right here and
and i think it's great i mean that that
image you just showed of all the
networks of obedient
people
obedient networks showing this thing on
command i think what we're seeing is the
final
swirling of credibility for the media
and democrats going down the drain i
think they're going to pay a price and i
think this this right this spectacle
right here is going to make it even
worse for them because the the you know
the difference between their concern
here and the concern about anybody else
including school children in elementary
schools
it's breathtaking
you and i entered journalism about the
same time over 30 years ago it seemed
honorable that it seems completely
shameful now it really does shameful
charlie hurt i appreciate you coming on
thank you
great to see you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight